c'est l'histoire surprenante d'un homme
qui cherche de quoi se
nourrir très loin des
supermarchés oh mon
dieu c'est sans doute le plus grosam que
j'ai
trouvé si j'arrive à le sortir de
là
ce n'est pas très différent d'une pomme
de
terre mon Dieu je ne sais pas si je vais
pouvoir le
sortir c'est tellement
gros tiens une balle de
golf on dirait qu'elle est là depuis un
moment retour à
l'envoyeur à 20 m de lui un terrain de
golf car nous ne sommes pas en pleine
nature mais dans un quartier chic de la
ville d'Orlando en Floride aux
États-Unis je me demande s'ils vont me
remarquer ils ne m'ont pas encore
remarqué mais s'il me voyait il pourrait
avoir
peur pas de chauss pas de
tshirt sauvage dans la
brousse mais bien je ne suis pas
sauvage je su justereain
je me sens très connecté à
cetteam et à travers lui très connecté à
la
terre ça fait au moins 10
kg ça m'a pris beaucoup de
temps mais au moins je n'aurais pas à
revenir pendant un
moment
cet homme c'est Rob Greenfield son
humilité et son humour inspire des
centaines de milliers de personnes sur
Internet aventurier activiste et
militant de l'écologie il veut changer
le monde et incarner tout le contraire
de la société de consommation aux
États-Unis une révolution
verte à 32 ans il veut sauver la planète
depuis son petit jardin avec des
solutions simples et
concrètes le petit monde de Rob
Greenfield commence derrière une
palissade dans un quartier résidentiel
d'Orlando en
Floride
il y a construit une petite maison en
bois 10 m
car l'espace d'un lit un bureau de
étagères quelques
livres et quelques t-shirt
vert il est adepte de la simplicité
volontaire très minimaliste j'aime que
les choses restent simples et mes
vêtements représentent cette
idée c'est se défaire de tout ce qui est
superflu dans la vie tout ce qui n'est
pas nécessaire et qui ne m'est pas utile
pour accomplir de grandes
choses je veux simplifier ma vie pour
faire ce que j'aime au lieu de gagner de
l'argent pour acheter des choses dont je
n'ai pas
[Musique]
besoinen tant simplifier sa vie qu'il ne
dépense presque plus
d'argent il n'a pas de loyer pas de
charg pas de compte
bancaire pas de travail rémunéré non
plus c'est sa définition de la
liberté W je m'attendais pas à
[Musique]
ça
il se remplit en quelques
secondes ici l'eau de pluie est récupéré
dans de grands barils pour toute la
maison chaque chose a une place et une
fonction et même les PL ont du
talent voilà mon papier
toilette je n'ai pas acheté de papier
toilette depuis 5
ans c'est super
doux et ça sent bon
un pe comme une
herbe vivre simplement c'est la seule
manière de vivre pour
moi une vill je NIR pas ça ne me
rendrait pas heureux je serai
malheureux quand je vais dans des
maisons trop extravagantes je ne me sens
pas
bien je ne trouve pas cela juste de
poser trop de choses alors que tant de
gens n'ont rien dans le
monde
malgré les apparences Rob Greenfield ne
vit pas couper du monde il n'a pas
abandonné son
ordinateur un demiillion d'abonnés
suivent ses aventures sur Facebook
YouTube et Instagram il publie tout ce
qu'il
[Musique]
fait j'aurais dû écrire il n'a peut-être
pas l'air appétissant à
l'extérieur mais c'est tout à fait bon à
l'intérieur comm pom de terre soit le
changement que tu veux voir dans le
monde cette phrase de gandhy collée sur
son ordinateur et le moteur de sa
[Musique]
vie nous vivons dans un monde qui est
très centré sur l'image je crois que ce
soit les photos ou les
vidéos les gens ont tendance à
comprendre les messages lorsqu'ils sont
visuels ça fait clic dans leur esprit
ma campagne la plus réussie dans ce
sens-l c'était trash me il y a 3 ans Rob
Greenfield s'était fait connaître à
travers cette vidéo
étonnante il avait porté sur lui tous
les déchets générés par un Américain
moyen pendant un mois à New York 2 kg de
déchet par jour et par personne il a
fait de ce chiffre une image
forte pourquoi je fais cela parce que
les déchets on y pense jamais on ne les
voit jamais on jette tout dans des
poubelles et on y pense plus et moi je
veux savoir de quoi j'aurais l'air si je
portais sur moi tous les déchets que je
crée pendant un
mois dans
trash je marchais dans les rues de New
York avec des déchets sur
moi et j'ai vu que les gens soudain
comprenaient comme si des petites
lumières s'allumaient dans leur tête et
qu'il se disais wouh je n'avais jamais
vu ça comme ça je comprends
maintenant
dans le même esprit Rob Greenfield est
allé plonger pendant des mois dans les
poubelles des grandes villes américaines
pour dénoncer le gaspillage alimentaire
immense aux
États-Unis et regardez le trésor qu'il y
a dans cette
poubelle des yaourts du pain du melon du
lait expiré hier même des bouteilles
d'eau des
sandwiches et toutes ces
salades du super pain de la poubelle je
vais passer une super
soirée aux États-Unis on jette la moitié
de ce que l'on produit la
moitié et voici un exemple de ce qu'il
retrouva chaque jour dans des
poubelles un Américain sur 7 ne mange
pas à sa fin alors que la réalité c'est
que nous avons assez pour nourrir deux
fois la population
américaine
plonger làdedans et trouver de la
nourriture tout à fait consommable a
permis aux gens de réaliser que ok voilà
un sac de pomme et elles sont toutes
bonnes voilà une dizaine de dont un seul
est craqué voilà des boîtes et des boî
de bar de céréales qui ont encore 30
jours avant d'être
Périm et j'ai tout mis par terre dans
des parcs publics pour en faire des
grandes
imagespr nous avons un
problème des photos et des vidéos qui
ont été vues partagé commenté imité même
partout dans le monde et qui lui donne
le sentiment d'être
[Musique]
utile tu arroses les plantes ou tu veux
que je le fasse lisa est la voisine la
plus proche de Rob
Greenfield tu as vu la photo de l'AM
j'ai trouvé unam de 12 k 12 k mais
comment tu l'as ramené à la maison je
vais te mon
bout mon
dieu c'est bien pour faire une soupe ça
donne une bonne consistance je sais pas
combien je pourrais en faire
avec donc tu vas le cuisiner pour notre
prochain dîner on va faire
ça
[Musique]
cette retraité hberge Rob Greenfield
gratuitement dans son jardin derrière sa
maison il lui a créé en échange le
potager dont elle
[Musique]
[Rires]
rêvait j'adore ce
jardin c'est un rêve qui se
réalise pendant 10 ans j'étais devant un
écran d'ordinateur toute la journée et
la seule chose à laquelle je rêvais
c'était d'avoir un
jardin je parle à mes plantes elles
savent bien
écouter je leur dis oh tu es si
jolie est-ce que c'est un bon
voisin oui c'est un bon voisin il a très
bon
cœur sa réputation l'a précédé je le
suivais déjà sur Facebook depuis un
moment avant qu'il n'emménage à
Orlando je connaissais sa façon de
porter l'attention sur la question des
déchets le fait de vivre en harmonie
avec
l'environnement donc lorsque j'ai appris
qu'il emménageait ici j'étais tellement
heureuse de profiter de son énergie et
de sa vision des choses à
Orlando en attendant de changer le monde
Rob Greenfield change déjà la vie de son
quartier à Orlando où il vit depuis 1 an
à peine il a offert se jardins potagers
à des m célibataires et plter une
centaine d'arbres fruitiers
communautaires avec des amis
[Musique]
jardiniers l'idée c'est de créer une
communauté de rapprocher les gens ce
n'est pas moi moi moi et toi toi toi le
but c'est d'avancer
ensemble il donne aussi des cours de
jardinage gratuit à ses
voisins voilà comment j'arrose pendant
les premières
semaines l'idée étant de ne pas trop
remuer la terre et risquer de déplacer
les graines et de détruire les jeunes
pouss vous avez des questions sur
l'arrosage si l'eau de la ville est
choré on l'utilise quand même dans un
monde idéal je neutiliserai pas mais
même quand on vient de planter
oui
ma philosophie du jardinage c'est faites
du bon boulot mais ne soyez pas
perfectionniste sinon vous allez perdre
beaucoup de temps et vous allez être
beaucoup trop
stressé grâce à tous ces projets de
jardinage Bill un cuisinier à la
retraite a retrouvé l'envie de sortir de
chez
lui je viens d'avoir 70 ans cette année
et ici il y a des gens qui ont 20 30 40
ans
on interagit on cuisine tous ensemble on
fait plein de choses
ensemble nous sommes une vraie
communauté qui comprend tous les âges
tous les genres il y a même des
enfants c'est ce qui s'est perdu au
cours des générations
précédentes et on se rend compte
maintenant en étant tous ensemble que
c'est ce qui nous
manquait même si elle n'a pas encore
gagné l'Amérique cette petite révolution
verte est en train de changer le visage
de ce
[Musique]
quartier il y a tellement de gens qui
sont en train de changer qui se réveille
et qui m'envoie des messages en me
disant continue Rob parce que tu m'as
inspiré et grâce à toi ma vie a
changé c'est ça qui me donne la force de
me lever le
matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Rob Greenfield plante aussi de nouvelles
idées dans les
esprits ce matin il est invité à l'école
primaire de son
quartier salut tout le
monde je suis content d'être là alors
vous avez quel âge
9 10
ans Avaz à peu près votre âge sur cette
photo et à cette époque j'adorais être
dehors j'étais passionné par la nature
j'aimais tous les
animaux maintenant j'ai 32 ans et
j'essaie de faire réfléchir les gens sur
l'environnement et de leur inspirer des
changements
positifs et on m'a dit que vous aviez vu
ma vidéo trash me vous l'avez tous
vu au bout de 10 jours je ne pouvais
plus aller nulle part sans qu'on me dise
c'est l'homme poubelle
c'était super
drôle combien d'entre vous ont entendu
parler du terme zéro déchet quelquesuns
cool ça c'est moi pendant un
mois quand je vivais ma vie habituelle
en essayant de créer le moins de déchets
possible et là c'est quand j'ai vécu
comme un Américain moyen pendant un mois
qui peut voir la différence c'est
flagrant
non je veux vous montrer deux autres
photos de mon copain du
Texas il est en
primaire et il a décidé de faire l'homme
poubelle dans son école ça c'est lui
après de semaines avec les déchets qu'il
a créé et là c'est lui après de semaines
de zéro
déchet levez la main si vous pensez à un
changement positif que vous voudriez
faire cool qui veut partager cela avec
nous avoir moins de déchets cool bonne
idée nettoyeer tous les déchets sur la
terre
nettoyer tous les déchets sur la terre
ça c'est bien mais en attendant tu peux
déjà commencer autour de toi parce qu'il
faut bien commencer quelque
part donc pour ceux qui n'ont pas levé
la main votre travail c'est de réfléchir
à un changement positif que vous
pourriez faire par exemple avoir une
bouteille d'eau
réutilisable manger moins de choses
emballées ou prendre plus souvent votre
vélo ça peut vous paraître difficile
parce que vous êtes jeune mais en
réalité les adultes écoutent vraiment
les enfants lorsqu'il parlent de
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est quelqu'un de bien
parce qu'il veut se débarrasser de tous
les déchets sur la terre et quand je
seraiis grand je voudrais être comme
lui c'est vraiment un super héros et ce
qu'il fait avec les déchets c'est très
utile je crois que nous les enfants on
peut changer le monde parce qu'on peut
prendre des habitudes plus
rapidement c'est plus facile que pour
les adultes
et la discussion
continue moi aussi je v faire trash ok
si tu le fais je te
soutiendrai tu
assoui j'ai 32 ans tu es millionnaire
non je n'ai que 1000 dollars j'ai promis
de ne pas être
millionnaire excuse-moi pourquoi tu n'as
pas de
chaussurorsp raison que je
je n'en ai pas besoin mais tu met jamais
de
chaussur j'orte rarement quand je vais
dans le Wisconsin et qu'il g oui je mets
des chaussures je crois que mon copain
et moi on va arrêter de porter des
chaussures cool vous me direz comment ça
se
[Rires]
passe alors c'est votre premier
jour le premier
jour faire un Mo comme ça on vient juste
de le
[Musique]
décider l'éducation à
l'écologie un sujet captivant pour tous
ces enfants qui grandissent loin de la
campagne dans des grandes villes
américaines Rob Greenfield lui a grandi
en pleine nature et n'a pas oublié ses
rêves d'enfant
[Musique]
quand je pense au petit garçon que
j'étais s'il me voyait aujourd'hui à 32
ans je peux dire avec certitude qu'il
serait extrêmement
fier il n'aurait jamais pu imaginer
l'homme qu'il
deviendrait il a passé son enfance près
des grands lacs du nord des États-Unis
dans le visconsin à l'autre bout du
[Musique]
pays marcha sa mère y habite toujours
aujourd'hui ça
marche alors il fait froid
oui il fait froid tout est
gelé
on dira que tu as oublié ce que
c'est je te montre par la fenêtre à quoi
ça ressemble
ici il fait en dessous de
zé c'est
dingue une seconde je crois que mon REP
est en train de
brûler fait la journaliste voulait te
poser une question elle peut la poser
maintenant
bonjour Comment
décriezv qu' est
maintenant comme vous
voulez quand il est né il était très
calme
serein il avait l'air éveillé à ce qu'il
se passait autour de
lui Rob aimait tellement aller pêcher et
être dehors qu'il avait installé une
tente sur le lac gelé qu'il laissait
toute la
nuit et il se réveillait le matin avant
d'aller à l'école pour aller y pêcher
je trouvais cela plutôt aventureux et
courageux je n'avais jamais vu personne
d'autre faire
cela Robin Greenfield est né dans les
années 80 dans une famille
hip une enfance très proche de la nature
mais aussi très différente de celle de
ses amis
américains j'ai grandi dans une famille
très
modeste nous étion enantsre dans en deux
pièces et j'avais honte de qui
j'étais honte d'être pauvre en
fait et donc j'étais accroché au rêve
américain une grande maison une super
voiture une famille normale avec une
mère un père et des enfants et pendant
très longtemps je pensais que c'est ce
que je voulais je voulais être un
millionnaire parce que je pensais que
c'était cela le
[Musique]
succès et plus je me concentrais sur le
fait d'être millionnaire sur ce rêve
américain plus je perdais l'esprit de
mon enfance qui était d'aimer la terre
la
nature de ne pas lui faire de mal de la
protéger au
contraire et je me suis rendu compte
qu'il fallait que je change totalement
ma
[Musique]
vie j'ai regardé des
documentaires j'ai lu des
livres et j'ai compris que toutes mes
actions la nourriture que je
mangeais la voiture que je conduisais
l'eau que j'utilisais les déchets que je
produisais tout était en train de
provoquer la destruction de la planète
que
j'aimais alors j'ai décidé de changer ma
vie étape par étape j'ai fait une longue
liste ce que je voulais changer je l'ai
accroché dans ma cuisine où je pouvais
l'avir tous les jours et mon but était
de faire un changement positif par
semaine
j'ai cela fait 7 ans que Rob Greenfield
lance des défis de plus en plus
grand 4
5 12
1 et ce jourl il est sur le point de
commencer la nouvelle grande aventure de
sa
vie
cela fait des mois qu'il se
prépare qu'est-ce que vous
faites je compte le poids exact de
nourriture que
j'ai j'ai des mangue beaucoup de
mangue quelques avocat pas beaucoup des
petits piments du jardin des graines de
citrouille un pot de miel et plein de
citrouille ili VI supermarché
ici tout ce qu'il y a je l'ai fait
pousser dans mon jardin où je l'ai glané
dans la
nature dans des espaces publics ou dans
des
parcs il veut passer un an sans rien
acheter à manger et se nourrir
exclusivement d'aliments qu'il récolte
dans son potager et qu'il glane dans la
nature c'est l'heure de dire adieu à
tout ce qui provient des magasins OK ok
ok alors tout cela doit partir parce que
tout cela vient des
épiceries le
riz les
lentilles ah l'huile d'olive ça ça va
faire
mal les raisins
secs ce sont mes derniers raisins de
l'année
à moins que j'arrive à en faire
moi-même qu'estce qui va vous manquer le
plus le
Chocolat le Chocolat va me manquer la
plupart du temps mais pourquoi vous
faites
ça je fais ça parce que c'est quelque
chose d'extrême qui va permettre au gens
de réfléchir qui va
lespir comme
moi mon but c'est que les gens fassent
une seule
chose par exemple planter des tomates et
du basilic sur leur
balcon ou faire un petit jardin devant
leur
maison que chacun commence par une
petite chose et se sent un petit peu
plus concerné par l'origine des aliments
qui nous permettent de
vivre et un peu plus connecté à la terre
en
général
le
maïs je ferais mieux de m'en
débarrasserune tentation chez
moi parce que le popcorn c'est une de
mes choses préféré et je ne peux pas
prendre le
risque pour moi c'est une expérience
humaine
profonde de voir c'est encore possible
dans une grande ville au milieu de toute
l'agitation
ur vivre de la
terre un défi
extrême mais qui a beaucoup de sens pour
lui sa voisine Lisa le soutien et semble
inspirée par cette nouvelle
aventure je comprends tout à
fait vous savez quand le balancier
penche trop d'un côté comme c'est le cas
pour notre société en ce moment où nous
sommes tellement rivés sur la
consommation en créant tellement de
déchets avec 40 % de notre nourriture
qui est
gaspillée donc parfois pour faire
pencher la balance il faut faire
l'extrême
inverse donc je pense que
Rob en prenant cette direction
opposée peut nous amener à trouver un
juste
milieu au lieu d'être autant plongé dans
la société de
consommation
mais Lisa se fait quand même du souci
pour son cher voisin il n'a jamais passé
un seul jour à se nourrir uniquement de
ce qu'il
[Musique]
produit je ne sais pas exactement ce que
je vais manger la semaine prochaine le
mois
prochain c'est un mystère qui reste
[Musique]
entier ça va être difficile
mentalementysi
éprouvant un peu de souci pour ma santé
mais j'espère qu'au contraire je serai
au mieux de ma
forme je ne peux pas abandonner je n'ai
pas le
[Musique]
choix la chance de Rob
Greenfield c'est qu'il vit en Floride
l'état du
soleil une péninsule dominée par une
nature fertile et
préservée son retour à la nature
commence donc par une journée de pêche
dans une
rivière avec l'un de ses amis
[Musique]
Terry Terry est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
y a des alligateurs par ici oui bien sûr
il y a des alligateur dans cette
rivière c'est la rivière Saint-Sébastien
qui est nourrie par une source d'eau
salée et sa matre c'est l'environnement
idéal pour les
alligators mais vous en avez déjà vu ici
oui beaucoup de 2,50 3
[Musique]
m ça m'a l'air bien tout
ça
[Musique]
allez Rob Greenfield tu peux le faire
ton repas en
dépend il lui aura fallu beaucoup de
patience pour pouvoir pêcher son premier
repas de la
[Musique]
journée
bien
joué vivre de la nature n'est pas
toujours
facile et Rob Greenfield est en train de
l'expérimenter je suis content et je
suis très
fatigué il est sans doute de ou 3 He de
l'après-midi je n'ai pas vraiment pris
de
petit-déjeuner je n'ai pas vraiment
assez mangé
aujourd'hui mais oui j'ai pris 10
poissons ce qui est suffisant pour les
deux prochaines
semaines prêt à repartir en
[Musique]
ville dis donc ça ne te dérange pas
d'avoir du sang de poisson et d'aller te
baigner avec des alligators j'y pense
mais je crois qu'il n'y a pas de quoi
s'inquiéter il y a vraiment peu de
risque si je me fais manger par un
alligator au moins j'aurais une belle
vie une très belle
[Musique]
vie cette nuit-là au coin du feu les
deux amis retrouvent le plaisir d'une
vie presque hors du
temps très loin du monde contemporain
qui ne les fait plus rêver depuis bien
longtemps je me sens vivant ce soir je
veux dire faire du canoé pêcher des
poissons les faire griller au feu de
bois contempler les étoiles audessus de
la tête ça ça me rend très
[Musique]
vivant je pense que dans le monde
confortable dans lequel nous vivons on a
souvent l'occasion de se sentir
quasiment mort ou
stagnant les aventures c'est ça qui rend
la vie plus
intense et l'aventure ne fait que
commencer